i am nick gillespie with reason TV it is
jun 28 Thursday June twenty-eighth
Obamacare decision has just come down
it's been hell upheld by the Supreme
Court we're talking with Peter Suderman
Peter is this a win for the Obama
administration yes this is a win for the
Obama administration and a loss for
those of us who oppose Obamacare however
the form of the decision that came down
was really unexpected and kind of kind
of weird and there were some silver
lining okay so how is this a I mean
you've talked about it as a bizarro
decision nobody quite saw this outcome
coming we know the court the case you
know the law was either going to be
upheld her down how is it a bizarre
decision well the decision that came
down was kind of the opposite of what
everyone expected for a couple of
reasons for one thing the mandate was
upheld as constitutional but not at
under the Commerce Clause which is which
was the primary argument for the
constitutionality of the individual
mandate is that is that Congress has the
right to regulate interstate commerce
and that falls under that even if it's
forcing somebody to do something they
wouldn't be doing otherwise right
exactly and so instead the court ruled
that the mandate was constitutional
under the Congress's taxing power which
was at it which is an odd ruling because
even a lot of liberal justices have
previously said that that argument just
doesn't fly but that's uh that's that
the ruling that just John Roberts
decided to go with and clearly most of
the the proponents of the laws steer
clear of the taxing argument I mean they
were put they were leaning on the
Commerce Clause rule right uh in
particular President Obama has insisted
on the record that the mandate is not a
tax and Democrats in Congress changed
the language of the bill during the the
bill writing process so that it would
not say that the mandate was a tax now
so what about the silver linings so that
there are two big silver linings the
first is that the majority opinion
written by Chief Justice Roberts does
accept that this is not justifiable
under the Commerce Clause and accepts
the activity in activity distinction
that opponents of the law have
have made for so long the other part and
this so that's good because it says I
mean even as it massively expands
Congress or the federal government's
power of our lives the Supreme Court is
at least saying hey the government
doesn't have absolute control right
they're saying that there are limits to
the Congress's power under the Commerce
Clause to regulate their limits to
Congress's ability to regulate commerce
and that this is beyond those limits the
other silver lining is that the Medicaid
expansion will not ruled
unconstitutional the court ruled that
states can opt out of the Medicaid
expansion without risking the loss of
existing federal Medicaid funds is a
little bit of a complicated issue but
basically uh the law had said that
states that continue to participate in
Medicaid uh have to uh expand Medicaid
as the law calls were otherwise they
will get zero federal Medicaid funds oh
this is is that that's not the case so
in in that small sense this state's i
mean the the Supreme Court actually
recognizes that the states have an
independent standing from the federal
government yes that's correct and that
the Medicaid expansion the way it was
structured the financing of it the
requirement that you buy in totally or
not at all was coercive uh even though
Medicaid is technically a voluntary a
lot of the you know the chattering
beforehand all focus on whether or not
Justice Kennedy was going to go limp in
the clinches it turns out to be John
Roberts did anybody see that coming uh
you know if you look at what Robert said
when he was confirmed that he wanted to
be an umpire that he wanted to be as
neutral as possible and sort of his long
history of insisting on extremely narrow
rulings this does fit with that to some
extent but no really most people were
not expecting Roberts to side with the
liberal majority and especially if
Kennedy sided with the conservative
right now to two final questions one is
what are the prospects for repeal or a
massive retrenchment against this law
how is that how can that play
uh the answer is that we what we won't
really know until after the election in
November depends on whether Mitt Romney
beat obama for the presidency it depends
on whether Republicans take back the
Senate if we have if Republicans in
control in the House the Senate and the
presidency i would say that there's
pretty good chances that the law will at
least be substantially changed if not
repealed otherwise it's also true i mean
you've you've written about how the
republicans have also started to find
parts of obamacare that day hey you know
we're okay with some of this stuff can
you talk about that right republicans
are gonna have a tough time it looks
like really committing to full repeal
and they a number of them have said look
we want to keep the good parts of
obamacare we want to keep some of the
insurance expansion provision some of
the perhaps some the pre-existing
condition regulations on insurers and so
there's going to be a debate in the
party over the next couple of weeks over
the next couple of days between now and
the election but really we're not going
to see any actual legislative movement
until after November between now and
then it's going to be a big political
battle and the biggest part of that is
going to be that Republicans are going
to take this decision and say look Obama
you said this was not a tax hike you
promise not to raise tax raise taxes on
middle-income earners and the Supreme
Court has said that this is only
justifiable as a tax your attack Tiger a
final final question now you know the
justifications for health care reform
were at least twofold I mean there were
more but one was that it was going to
help reduce health care costs going
forward is there any chance at this bill
or that this legislation in whatever
form it ends up implementing is actually
going to cut costs and the second is it
was supposed to expand coverage to a lot
of people you know 40 million 50 million
you hear different numbers of who are
uninsured this is going to increase the
insured rolls by 30 million 32 million
will it actually help the people who are
now getting coverage will it will it
help them be healthier and live happier
and better lives it may be that many
enough states opt out of the Medicaid
expansion that the Medicaid that the
numbers are significantly lower than
then we expect their on but will that
coverage Nestle you know it does that
mean much for the uninsured it's really
tough to say the jury is still out on
the health value of of being covered by
health insurance we've seen in health
insurance experiments that people say
they feel better but we haven't seen a
lot of objective health measures by
which they actually are better and so
like I said the jury's still out on the
cost issue look CBO says that this law
is going to cost trillion dollars in new
spending is it going to bring down the
cost of insurance well it's going to
subsidize the cost of private insurance
but as we know from the long history of
health subsidies and other subsidies
when you subsidize something what
happens is that the market raises the
price to account for those subsidies and
so I think it's at least very unlikely
that ultimately this law helps contain
insurance the cost of insurance premiums
help slow the growth of medical spending
overall thank you Peter Suderman of
Reason magazine big cover of healthcare
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you